well he's the most controversial man on
the planet present company except his
social media influencer Andrew Tate the
former professional kickboxer and his
brother have been locked up for three
months in a Romanian jail over
allegations of human trafficking and
rape they've not been charged have now
been released on house arrests they
remain under investigation arriving home
early this month this is what Andrew
Tate had to say
well I've been in one room since last
year so uh it's a little bit emotional I
want to give respect firstly to the
judges who hurt us today because they
were very attentive and they listened to
us and and they let us free I I truly
believe that Justice will be served in
the end there is zero percent chance of
me being found guilty of something I
have not done
so joining us now is Andrew Tate's
lawyer Tina Tina thank you very much
indeed for joining us again on Piers
Morgan and sensing where are we with
this case because it does seem very
strange that there is still no sign of
any charges or of them being released
hi peers we're certainly a lot better
off today than the last time I was on
your show as you recall back then the
tape brothers were still detained in a
Romanian jail cell now they have been
released on house arrest so relative to
that you know they're doing much better
now and we've taken a big step in the
right direction however this month
actually marks the one year since this
investigation first began and the fact
that they're still on house arrest and
the fact that they're restraint and
their Liberty uh their Liberty is still
restrained and they're not free to move
about the way anybody else would while
this very prolonged investigation
continues
is obviously substantially troubling and
frustrating to them so even though a few
weeks ago we took a big step in the
right direction we're still not all the
way there and we are we're looking
forward to the day that the Romanian
authorities decide that they won't be uh
that they conclude the investigation and
decide that they won't be seeking an
indictment in this case what are the
rules of the house race I only asked
because before I came on air I noticed
that Tristan tweeted me several times
about tonight's show actually
um is that him are they allowed to tweet
personally the the two brothers
they are the only real restrictions that
they have other than the fact that
they're confined to their house is that
they can't communicate with either the
two other women who also like them or on
house arrest who are being investigated
alongside them in this matter and any
other Witnesses who have been mentioned
in the file beyond that there are no
other restrictions as far as
communication with friends or family or
having visitors as well as social media
activity there's obviously been a an
enormous amount of global coverage of
this and obviously they remain innocent
until or if they're ever charged or
proven guilty how are they actually
doing uh themselves I mean some weird
condition to to be living under house
arrest
it is again it's it's relative to where
they were a few weeks ago they are doing
much better of course
um however the three months in jail
certainly took a toll on them and I know
Andrew has told me he right now has a
lot of trouble sleeping he can't sleep
for more than two hours a night and you
know it really took a toll so they're
struggling with the process on what
they've been through but they are now
focused mostly on just regaining they
believe a strong strong body is a strong
mind they're back to their training and
fitness and health and focusing on those
things and trusting their attorneys in
the process to play out and for them to
eventually clear their names the court
of public opinion has been depending on
what you read uh particularly on social
media but obviously they have this huge
platform each of them it's either been
brutally Savaged against them
pre-judging everything and assuming
their guilt or it's been the complete
opposite that they are the victim of a
shocking miscarriage of Justice can they
get any kind of fair trial even if it
was to come to that given the enormous
amount of coverage
while we're certainly hoping it doesn't
come to that but yes all of those things
that you said really do jeopardize
somebody in a case like this always
these high-profile cases We Believe
oftentimes the defendant can't get a fur
trial because there is such
unfortunately a presumption of guilt in
these types of cases there is a lot of
misinformation spread prior to the case
actually being heard and opinions are
formed and a lot of times again it's not
based on the actual evidence so I think
it is very challenging to have a fair
trial under circumstances such as such
as the tape brother case here however
again we are optimistic that the
evidence is not going to support an
indictment and that it won't come to
that if it does go to trial would it be
a jury trial or just a judge
a judge
the I think since we last spoke in the
last several weeks actually three
British women have come forward to say
they were abused and sexually assaulted
by Andrew Tate and a crowdfunding to sue
him for compensation they're all in
their 20s or early 30s they worked as
webcam models for Andrew they say in
Luton from 2013 onwards claim they were
abused poorly paid and threatened to
stop him going to the police what's your
response to that
well first to be clear there's no
there's no new lawsuit and there's
certainly these are not new allegations
these are old allegations from 2014 and
2015 that I would seriously you know I
think there's questions about the timing
and motivation as to why this is now
being brought up I certainly don't think
it's a coincidence that you know right
after they've been released on house
arrest that this has now again come up
but just to be clear what what this case
right now is it's three Anonymous women
who have not come forward with their
identities
are seeking crowd uh funding and they're
seeking um I think 50 000 pounds to
begin with and I believe they've raised
at this point a little bit over 8 000
pounds and this is so that they could
sue the Bro Sue Andrew Tate for
compensation so they're basically asking
the public to fund their efforts to get
money from Andrew Tate and what's
bizarre about this aside from the fact
that these same allegations were
previously investigated by the UK
authorities who decided that there was
no evidence and it was not sufficient to
pursue charges against Andrew Tate but
putting that aside what's strange to me
as an attorney certainly in my
experience cases of this type are often
brought by attorneys on what we call a
contingency fee basis which means that
the attorney if they believe in the Case
Files the lawsuit
prosecutes it and then from the monies
that they recover for their client they
take a percentage of that so to me it's
very strange that instead of
pursuing the case like that which would
typically be done they're asking the for
the public for donations to fund this
attempt for these Anonymous women again
to make money from Andrew Tate and I
think it's really important to remember
cases like Eleanor Williams which
recently I know got a lot of attention
and I saw your interview with one of the
men who uh Eleanor had falsely accused
and there are cases where women go to
crazy and extreme lengths I know in that
case she had created fake social media
profiles she had sent herself
um you know fake messages that were
reported initially to be evidence she
went so far as to purchase a hammer and
to self-inflict severe injuries I mean
just to jump into we're running out of
time that was an outrageous case and
that she was a total fantasist and a
very evil one at that I think look to be
fair to your clients they are innocent
until proven guilty they've not been
charged this has been going on for a
year they've been held in prison for
month after month after month they're
now effectively under a sort of Home
prison and you do think at some stage
that out of fairness and Justice they
are either going to be charged or
released and we'll see what happens but
I think next week you're expecting to
get an update right
we will get an update next week because
they can only extend this house arrest
for a total combined with the three
months that they already served it's a
total of six months in Romania so if
they seek an application it will be made
next week well I hope we can talk to you
again after that development Tina
Glendon thank you very much indeed thank
you pierce